we've used definite integral's to find
areas what I want to do now is to see if
we can use a definite integral to find
an arc length what do I mean by that
well if I start at this point on the
graph of a function and if I were to go
to this point right over here not in a
straight line we know already how to
find the distance in a straight line but
instead we want to find the distance
along the curve if we were to lay a
string along the curve what would be
this distance right over here that's
what I'm talking about by arc length by
arc length and we could think about it
is okay well that's going to be from x
equals a to x equals B along along along
this curve so how could we do it well
the one thing that integration integral
calculus is teaching us is that when we
see something that's changing like this
what we could do is we can break it up
into infinitely small parts infinitely
small parts that we can approximate it
with things like lines and rectangles
and then we could take the infinite sum
of those infinitely small parts so let
me break up my arc length into let me
break it up into infinitely small
sections of arc length so let me call
each of those infinitely small sections
of my arc length
eh-eh-eh-eh I guess I could say a length
of differential and arc length of
differential I'll call it D s D s now
I'm going to draw it much bigger than
when at least I conceptualize what a
differential is just so that we can see
it and what do I mean by breaking it up
into these DS's well if that's a d s and
then let me do these others in another
color that's another change in
infinitely small change in my in my arc
length another infinitely small change
in my arc length if I summed if I summed
all of these ds's together I'm going to
get the arc length the arc length if I
take is going to be the integral of all
of these ds's all of these d s is sum
together over this interval so we can we
can denote it like this but this doesn't
help me right now this is in terms of
this arc length the differential I we
know how to do things in terms of D X's
and D wise
so let's see if we can re-express this
in terms of D X's and DUIs
so if we go on a really really small
scale once again we can approximate this
is this is this is going to be a line we
just the way that we approximated area
with rectangles at first but if you have
an infinite number of infinitely small
rectangles you're actually approximating
a a non rectangular region the area of a
non rectangular region and similarly
we're approximating with lines here but
they're infinitely small and there's an
infinite number of them you are actually
finding the length of the curve well
just focusing on this as a line for now
so this distance right over here I'm
just going to try to express it in terms
of D X's and dys so this distance right
over here that's DX that's it you could
view this as an infinitely small change
in X and this distance right over here
this is a D Y and once again I'm you
being loosey-goosey with differentials
really to give you conceptual
understanding not a rigorous proof but
it'll it'll give you a sense of where
the formula for arc length is actually
coming from so based on this you can see
the D s could be expressed as based on
the Pythagorean theorem as equal to DX
squared plus D Y squared or you could
rewrite it as the square root of DX
squared plus dy squared so we can
rewrite this we could say this is the
same thing as the integral of instead of
writing D s I'm going to write it as the
square root of DX squared DX squared
plus dy squared plus D Y squared once
again this is straight out of the
Pythagorean theorem now this is starting
to get interesting effort in terms of DX
and dy is but they're getting square
there are no radical sign what can I do
to simplify this or at least write it in
a way that I know how to integrate well
I could factor out a DX squared so let
me just rewrite it this is going to be
the same thing as the integral of the
square root I'm going to factor out a DX
squared DX squared x times 1 plus dy
over DX squared notice this and
this is the exact same quantity if I
distribute this DX squared I'm going to
get this right up here and now I can
take the DX squared out of the radical
and so this is going to be this is going
to be the integral of let me write that
in that white color the integral of 1
plus dy DX squared this is interesting
because we know what dy DX is this is
the derivative of our function dy DX
squared and if you take the DX squared
out of the radical the square root of DX
squared is just going to be DX it's just
going to be DX it's just going to be DX
now this is really interesting because
we know how to find this between two
bounds we can now take the definite
integral from A to B since now we are
integrating a bunch of D X's or we're
integrating with respect to X we can say
ok x equals a to x equals B let's take
the sum of the product of this
expression and DX and this essentially
this is the formula for arc length the
formula for arc length and if this looks
complicated in the next video we'll see
that it's actually fairly
straightforward to apply although
sometimes the math gets hairy if you
wanted to write it in a slightly
different notation you could write this
as equal to the integral from A to B x
equals a to x equals B of the square
root of 1 plus instead of dy DX I could
write it as F prime of X F prime of x
squared F prime of x squared DX so if
you know the function if you know what f
of X is take the derivative of it with
respect to x squared add it to one take
the square root and then multiply and
then take the definite integral of that
with with respect to X from A to B and
we'll do that in the next video